de cette audition ah ça y est vous nous
avez en en visuel et
que pas nous on
pas directeur INTERAL des douanes depuis
la Martinique très bien donc je vais
procéder sans que vous nous voyez mais
si au moins vous avez le son on va
attaquer comme ça parce qu'on a des
problèmes techniques on s'en excuse lors
de la l'audition
précédente je vais vous proposer qu'on
qu'on passe à la phase de prestation de
serment qui est requise devant une
commission d'enquête donc je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête est passible
des peines prévues aux articles 434- 13
434-14 à 434-15 du code pénal et je vais
vous inviter chacun d'entre vous à
prêter serement de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité à lever la main
droite et à dire je le
jure dans quel ordre en même temps tous
on gagnera du
temps je le jure je prête de dire la
vérité la vérité je le jure je prête
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité je le jure donc je prête serment
de dire la vérité je le jure oui Richard
Marie directeur des douan Anglian je
prête serment de dire toute la vérité et
je le jure merci hugali directeur
interrégional des douanes en Martinique
je dis je je le jure très bien et et on
suppose que la main est levée merci
beaucoup euh on vous a adressé un un
questionnaire pour orienter
vos notre échange est-ce que on peut
vous proposer un un échange liminaire
sur la base de ce que vous avez à nous
dire et puis ensuite le rapporteur
Étienne blanc et les sénateurs et
sénatrices qui sont présents ici vous
poseront quelques questions
complémentaires je vous laisse le la
parole euh très bien ben Philippe Jos
directeur territorial de la police
nationale en Guyane euh sur si je
reprends un petit peu on va dire les les
les quelques éléments principaux qui
ressortent de de des questions adressé
je vous diraiis la chose suivante c'est
que évidemment le la problématique du
trafic de stupéfiants est très prignante
en Guyane et notamment parce que nous
sommes une zone de passage qui exporte
massivement vers les territoires
métropolitains ça c'est le le constat
que que tout le monde
connaît de ce constat au cours des des
périodes de la période écoulée la plus
récente on va dire sur les mois où la où
l'année estcoulée nous n'avons pas
constaté d'évolution notable dans la
teneur de ce trafic c'est-à-dire qu'il
reste euh centré autour de la cocaïne et
qui ne se développe pas en tout cas de
manière vers d'autres produit et tout ce
qui a trait au cannabis l'herbe la
résine demeure quand même marginal en
tout cas à notre connaissance euh sur ce
qui a trait à la criminalité connexe euh
il y a évidemment un impact mais je sans
développer plus on y reviendra peut-être
il est bien moindre que ce que vous
pouvez constater dans les territoire
métropolitain comme à Marseille ou
ailleurs où il y a véritablement des
guerres de gang qui se mènent autour du
trafic et du contrôle des points de Deal
les plus rentablebl ici nous ne
connaissons pas de de situation en tout
cas similaire pour l'heure euh pour ce
qui est des moyens mis à la disposition
services de sécurité par l'État pour
lutter contre contre ce phénomène ils
sont en tout cas pour ce qui concerne la
police conséquent euh et notamment
évidemment l'ofast qui est un peu ben le
bras armé en la matière pour l'ensemble
du du territoire que ce soit en zone
police ou en zone gendarmerie avec
évidemment une focale sur tout ce qui a
trait euh à l'aéroport la coordination
se passe très très bien je pense que
notre notre présence réunie tous les
quatre aujourd'hui en témoigne entre les
différents services de l'État
en la matière gendarmerie douane et et
police ça ça ne de difficulté on a un
offaste qui au jour d'aujourd'hui
fonctionne à mon sens de manière très
intéressante et et en tout cas bien
mieux que par le par le passé euh avec
une cross qui qui se développe aussi
dans son activité et qui produit
maintenant ben de la opér synthèse qui
sont
diffus
partenaire en ce qui concerne les les
résultats obtenus euh et tout
spécifiquement sur la problématique du
trafic aérien qui est qui
est guyanaise je je rappellerai quelques
euh en
2020 il y avait eu 311
personnes sur les aéroport parisien
d'orli et de rassie et 526 kg saisis euh
depuis euh euh le début de l'année 2023
ces chiffres ont notablement diminué 138
et 221 kg ce qui fait donc une
diminution de 69 % des
interpellations par nos collègues euh
d'arli et de roissi euh concomitamment
nous n'avons jamais interpellé autant de
mules euh sur la plaque de l'aéroport et
avec une augmentation de 26 % des
interpellations nous avons euh grâce à
la à la préfecture pu mettre en place
euh le dispositif on parlera
certainement plus longuement à savoir le
fameux 100 % auquel participe
directement euh la gendarmerie et les
douanes aussi euh pour pouvoir faire en
sorte benah de de d'éviter par un
travail sur le individualisé donc de
travailler sur les flux pour éviter les
arrivées massives euh de ces
personnes communément les mules euh sur
le territoire national
euh enfin euh euh sur la problématique
de la saturation des services cette
augmentation tant
de judiciaire mais aussi la mise en
place de cette activité administrative
soutenue on a Ré à l'absorber grâce
justement à ce travail de coordination
avec l'apport de la gendarmerie sur sur
le l'aéroport et aussi avec avec les
douanes qui ont développé leur leur
propre process je laisserai en parler et
euh un travail un gros travail de
réorganisation au niveau de la police
nationale avec une répartition plus
opérante plus plus plus efficiente entre
nos différentes branches entre nos
différents services entre l'ofaste d'une
part le stpj de l'autre mais aussi la
PAF pour faire en sorte que Ben cet
afflux de de travail soit soit pris en
compte par chacun ce que notre réforme
de la direction territoriale a permis
euh très rapidement quelques points
comme ça la coopération avec les état
voisin qui est quand même on va dire
très très limité euh le travail du
renseignement qui est en voie de
développement et qui on va dire des des
premiers retours intéressants puisque le
renseignement territorial qui fait parti
partie participe lui aussi au cross et
produit de la documentation
opérationnelle euh puis sur sur ce qui
est de de de notre de nos relation avec
les élus locaux elles sont en en la
matière pr inexistant mais en soit c'est
pas forcément choquant et sur quelques
thématiques si vous voulez on pourra y
revenir après que ce soit sur la joint
inter agency task force ou la
problématique des des gardes-côtes où là
on n'est pas directement concerné comme
ça peut être le cas par contre et en
Martinique voilà je veux pas monopoliser
le temps de parole voilà ce que je
pouveis vous dire de manière j'espère
synthétique bah du coup ce que je
propose c'est que les uns et les autres
vous complétez ce propos liminire en
ajoutant ce qui est un peu différent ce
qui mérite d'être nuancé vu de vos
administrations
respectives très bien donc je suis le
général Jean-Christophe sainttif je
commande la gendarmie de Guan depuis un
an et demi
et déjà pour souligner le le travail ici
qui est fait conjointement avec la
police et les douanes effectivement
où tous les jours enfin on travaille
main dans la main sur sur la plupart des
dispositifs notamment à
l'aéroport dispositifs on en a parler
c'est le 100 % où la gendarmerie
complète le dispositif par la
effectivement des contrôles avec des
gendarmes mobiles qui viennent appuyer
euh notamment la police au frontière
dans le dans le dans les dans les
contrôles des des individus qui
effectivement seraient potentiellement
porteur de de cocaïne euh mais aussi la
la gendarmerie complète complètement le
disposondeur du territoire et c'est
effectivement le finalement l'essence
même de la gendarmerie puisque en plus
de du point de contrôle effectivement au
niveau de l'aéroport où là tout le monde
sait effectivement que qu'ils vont être
contrôlés 100
% la gendarmerie a mis en en place un
point de contrôle routier à Margot alors
Margot vous le trouverez pas sur une
carte c'est c'est une crie qui a la
sortie de Saint-Laurent du Maroni donc
c'est sur la commune de Saint-Laurent du
Maroni et ce point de contrôle routier
de Margot contrôle
tout de faç mais cas 24 heur sur 24 7
jours sur 7 les véhic de Saint-Laurent
de Maroni et qui se dirigent vers vers
Cayan alors c'est des contrôles
d'identité on est dans la zone des 20 km
donc on n pas de difficultés pour ça et
puis sous réquisition régulière du
procureur de la République en ce qui
concerne les coffres il y a une
coordination avec la Cross du point de
contrôletier puisque tous les les
personnes criblé on rentrera si vous
souhaitez toutes les personnes qui sont
criblées par la Cross sont transmises au
point de contrôle routier de Margot pour
avoir un un pré-travail on va dire sur
sur ces gens-là en tout cas une une
vigilance particulière sur euh sur les
véhicules qui utilise et sur euh les euh
éventuellement si euh on des dans leur
véhicule ou dans ou ou dans leur ENF par
de la cocaïne dans leur véhicule ou dans
dans leur bagage euh donc il y a un vrai
un vrai travail effectivement en amont
euh dans la profondeur du territoire et
qui effectivement derrière est complété
par des contrôles aléatoires sur les
alors
euh point in c'està-dire en 2023 avec
avec tous ces dispositifs qui nous la
gendarmie dans dans le territoire sur le
territoire on on a on a saisi moins de
cocaïne puisquon est à aujourd'hui au
moment où je vous parle à 55 kg on est
en avait 75 kg en 2022 et 78 kg en 2021
sur l'année
complète et on a interpellé Mo voilà
nous les mules comme comme je vous
disais on les contrôle de façon
aléatoire un peu partout sur le
territoire donc on sent que on nous on a
l'impression effectivement dans des
contrôles aléatoires que euh le le
nombre de mules qui circulent en Guan à
à a diminué
euh un un point sur la criminalité
connexe alors euh je Connex c'est un peu
enfin moi je dirais alternative ici en
ce moment en tout cas c'est ce qu'on est
en train de vivre sur Saint-Laurent du
morani ce n'est qu'une impression hein
ça fait quelques mois on a une montée en
puissance de la délinquence sur
délinquence
acquisitive notamment lié à des volam
armé des armes de point essentiellement
des armes de chasse et pour des
préjudices qui portent sur des
téléphones portables sur de l'argent
liquide et sur des bijoux des des
délinquance assez
violente c'est les muleséalement les
auteurs de Vama mais on a l'impression
en tout cas on a d'une monté en
puissance de des des vols sur
Saint-Laurent du Maroni peut-être dû
aussi au fait que bah il y a moins
d'argent qui revient du trafic de
stupéfiant sur sa Saint-Laurent du
Maroni
et en tout cas pour l'instant il est
quand même assez sévère sur sur les 11
premiers mois de l'année à plus 70 % de
vol àé sur Saint-Laurent du Maroni euh
et et une augmentation de la délinquance
assez voilà de de voie publique de la
délincance acquisitive assez assez assez
importante donc c'est un impact c'est
potentiellement pour nous un impact
de au niveau de au niveau de l'aéroport
euh et du fait que effectivement il y a
moins d'argent en tout cas ce qu'on
qu'on espère euh du trafic de
stupéfiants euh sur sur la guenne en
revanche on a un un phénomène nouveau
effectivement il est émergent alors
euh qu'on a qu'on est en train de
percevoir c'estàd qu' au point de
contrôle de Mario on a on a saisi depuis
un mois 50 kg de cannabis euh
en provenance du Guyana ou du Surinam et
cette drogue elle est pas
censé c'est c'est ce cannabis c'est pour
de la consommation locale ce qui est pe
cocaïne donc on est sur de de sentir
l'émergence d'un trafic localement de
cannabis pour la consommation des guané
et ça c'est un phénomène nouveau qui est
effectivement tout à fait émergent
depuis à peine 2 mois ici en Guyane
alors est-ce que c'est un moyen pour l'
assez comment dire on a on on n pas
encore pu évidemment analyser tout ça
précisément mais est-ce que c'est aussi
un moyen de récupérer de l'argent qu'on
a plus par le trafic de cocaïne c'est
une une possibilité qu'il faut envisager
euh voilà
sinon je penseement sur la
coopération policière avec le Brésil du
Surinam à Notter quand même que nous
avons un centre de coopération policière
euh effectivement saint-georgeapoc qui
nous permet donc dans lequel on a un
policier
de de la PAF on a effecement trois
gendarmes et on a aussi
deos de brésilien donc euh la
coopération policière avec le le Brésil
est tout de même organisée hein
évidemment avec
avecvec donc avec le Brésil ce qui est
de fait moins le cas avec le sur unam
puisque même si on a des échanges
réguliers et d'ailleurs on sort d'un
nous venons de faire un
par avec la police du du Surinam et la
justice du Surinam sur les trafics de
cocaïne justement elle est quand même
moins développée sur le plan
opérationnel et effectivement c'est
c'est on voit bien que les trafics de
cocaïne viennent du essentiellement du
Surinam ils viennent pas du Brésil
euh voilà quelques grandes lignes mais
après évidemment je répondrai à toutes
vos
questions merci on laisse continuer
oui bonjour je m'appelle Richard Marie
je suis directeur des douanes depuis
presque 2 ans guyan euh moi ce qui me
paraît important de
préciser les forces de sécurité
intérieur et la douane qui n'appartient
pas aux forces de sécurité intérieure en
tant que tel ont vécu avec la mise en
place du 100 % à partir du 31 octobre
2022 une véritable révolution
copernicienne c'est-à-dire que avant
chacun faisait des saisies donc pas mal
mul et tous les jours on saturait les
services on saturait notamment les
services d'enquête dont l' don à mon
sens n'est pas un service pour le
traitement des mules mais pour le
démantellement des filièr mais encore
faut-il avoir du temps pour démer des
filières ne pas être
engorgé donc cette réflexion collective
qui est partie d'une de la mise en place
d'unetive d'entrave et de refoulement
qui repose donc sur les arrêtés antimul
elle été mise en place de manière
totalement à l'origine avec de la
procureur avec moi-même
et ce que ça ce que ça donnait puisque
alors on ignore combien il y avait
potentiellement de mules par avion et le
nombre de mules par avion était
manifestement totalement sousestim
puisque lorsqu'on a commencé les
premiers
tests basique envoyer demander aux
compagnies aériennes voyer au passagers
à l'ensemble des passagers un message
par SMS en leur disant attention demain
arrivriver 4h avant parce que il va
avoir un contrôle 100 % police et douan
et on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
entre 30 et 50 nocho par
vol donc bon par on en a déduit que
normalement sur sur un vol commercial
classique vous pouvez avoir 5 10 nocho
maximum donc on on s'est rendu compte on
avait en fait entre 30 et 50 mules par
vol d'où la mise en place de cette
stratégieution copernicienne notamment
pour la douane accepter de faire moins
de
quantité moins d'affaires mais des
affaires de plus belles qualité qui
permettent de démanteler après en aval
des filières et en amont par un travail
d'enquête réalisé justement par des
policiers spécialisés soit soit l'ofast
c'estàdire que rendu compte rapidement
qu'on a vu les profils des passeurs
complètement changer c'est dire que la
douane a été repositionnée sur son cœur
de métier c'est-à-dire le contrôle de la
marchandise et en aéroport le contrôle
de la marchandise ben c'est le contrôle
des valises c'est très
basique ça marche bien parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que on fait beaucoup moins
d'affaires mais on fait des belles
affaires avec des doubles fonds avec des
quantités intéressantes et que par ces
affaires on arrive à mettre en place à
démentler à mettre en évidence des
réseaux criminels qui peuvent être même
inter au
circuit voilà ce que je pourrais
rajouter et préciser également que les
brigades essentiellement de
Saint-Laurent du Maroni parce que
effectivement la la cocaïne vient
beaucoup plus du Surinam que du Brésil
et bien sont concernés par ce dispositif
100 % puisque c'est à la fois des
brigades qui peuvent faire direct qui
servent également cette unité sert
également de de vigis et d'alerte pour
des contrôles réalisés en
aéroport voilà et pour ce qui est des
relations avec les élus bien évidemment
la douane nous on est dans une position
tout à fait particulière puisqu'on
appartient au ministère des comptes
publics et donc nous avons des relations
privilé lu notamment la collectons l'ro
de
mer voilà ce que je pourrais dire
rapidement merci monsieur
[Musique]
josés je voulais ajouter donc présenter
mon
serviceice
interministériel la direction
territorialeousugmenté nos effectifs et
nous donne deux missions principales le
traitement des
des des réseaux et cette mission a été
en grande partie rempli cette année
cette
année on a été réorganisé en fin d'année
2020 avec la
création
réseau le chef de douane qui bien
évidemment euh euh précise que euh le le
démantellement de réseau est essentiel
notamment euh en guyan je voulais juste
ajouter euh qu'au niveau du des produits
qui étaient saisis euh en
guyan que le le les taux était était de
plus en plus élevé la la cocaïne est de
plus en plus forte les retours du euh
parlent de de de pourcentage de 85 à 90
% donc la cocaïne est de de meilleure
qualité euh on voit que le le la mise en
place des des contrôles 100 % fait à
l'aéroportre et administratif
euh les trafiquants
euh
toujours essaye par des moyens détournés
notamment la compromission
de de faire passer pour qu'elle
arriveo euh donc
développer un
partenariat en espérant option et
policière soit soit la meilleure
possible prochains mois ou les les
prochaines
années
merci qui n'a n'est pas
intervenu monsieur gay encore une fois
oui c'était juste en tout cas ma ma
présence justifier principalement si on
est
les éventuels détournements de trafic
vers la zone Caraïbe comme on l'a pu
faire et l'évoquer lundi voilà c'est qui
est une réalité qui s'est mise en place
au début 2023 à la suite de
la de la mise en place du 100 % en luyan
même si c'est resté en tout cas dans les
contestations qu'on a pu faire
relativement mesuré et par contre ce qui
est voilà ce qui est évident les
les mais nos collègues on en parlait un
petit peu c'est que le territoire dans
lequel se trouve la Guyane avec des
longues frontière fuvial sont voilà
relativement difficiles à maîtriser pour
toutes les forces de sécurité réunies et
que les les contrôles en deuxè rideau o
au départ qui ont été instaurés était
véritablement une avancée extrêmement
efficace par rapport à la lutte contre
ces produits
stupéfiants alors notre rapporteur
Étienne blanc va vous poser quelques
questions complémentaires oui
et vous avez été
plusieurs à aborder directement ou
indirectement
et le contrôle des mules notamment le
contrôle à l'aéroport et euh la gestion
de ce contrôle et la gestion des des
procédures qui permettent ensuite de
traduire ses mules devant les
juridictions et les sanctionner est-ce
que vous auriez quelques suggestions à
faire et sur l'identification des points
de complexité et sur l'identification
des points et des procédures qui sont
coûteuses aussi sur des procédures qui
je dis pas inutiles mais qui pourrai
être simplifié et sur des pratiques qui
elles aussi pourrai être lifié est-ce
que vousz des suggestions à nous faire
dans ce
domaine je vais essayer de répondre euh
je crois que justement enfin euh face au
au au constat euh qu'on a que nos
services que nos prédécesseurs ont
dressé que la la seule
judiciarisation de la lutte contre le
trafic était inopérante euh il a été
décidé de mettre en place euh un
dispositif fondé sur le recours à des
actes administratifs d'où les arrêtés de
refus d'embarqu c'est
ça d'avoir un impact massif sur
tel que nous
les auparavant on faisait une interpelle
de trois Interpel au bout d'un moment de
toute façon on saturait toutes nos
capacités nos capacités traitement
judiciire nos capacités de de ces
personnes parce que il faut les
médicaliser
après pouvoir apporter une réponse
pénale on va dire dans
des parce que les actuellement copj
c'est je crois jusqu'en mai 2000 25 je
crois que je ça donc autant dire que ça
voilà ça s prête un petit peu à sourire
donc c'est
vraiment les moyens euh comment dire
distincts et et et là là-dessus je crois
que c'est notre réussite he collective
je je voilà j'ose le j'ose le mot euh la
la réussite de l'État c'est d'avoir
réussi à mettre en place et de garder
depuis plus d'un an un
dispositif qui nous permet d'empêcher la
grande majorité euh des personnes qui
sont désire
avec des produits stupéfiants d'arriver
en métropole parce que c'est ça aussi
qui fait la spécificité de la cuillane
c'est que le mode de transport et
privilégié c'est l'ingestion et c'est ça
qui Fa tout si nous avions des personnes
qui comme on va la majorité des des des
contrées usé du
mode par des valises ou par des des
transports àord même s'il y en a aussi
dans les chaussures dans des perruques
dans des
culotes on en trouve encore mais
c'estité grosso
modo qui r parce que quand vous faites
des avec des g cocaïne avec
eux une
fois qu' n'en avait pas un géré B après
vous
gérez même si elle dure 96
he
sur le devenir
du de prendre en compte la
dimension
et qui sont implanté à
l'hôpital nbre
limité parce que
ça de prendre ce qu'on
appelleultip dans des chambes non
sécuris
pour qu'elle ne s'échappe pas euh
évidemment surtout pour du produit dès
lors qu'
donc que nous on souhaite c'est que en
tout cas que on
pu qui est pour pouvoir avoir un
impact sur le trafic de stupéfiant alors
on je vous cache pas qu'on a de de
du cours alternatif là du son alternatif
et que ça saute beaucoup on vous entend
assez mal est-ce que ce point précis là
en réponse au rapporteur vous pourrez
nous le mettre par écrit parce que ça
nous paraît très très très très
intéressant et je pense qu'on en on a
besoin de cette réponse de manière très
claire par écrit al je crois que j'avais
une question de Laurent burgois et de
Marie Laur merci monsieur le Président
merci messieur moi j'aurai deux
questions rapides la première y y a-t-il
un GIR en Guyane sinon croyez-vous qu'il
serait opportun d'en créer un et ma
deuxième question liée à la corruption
c'est que lorsqu'on parle
narcotrafiquant malheureusement il y a
corruption avez-vous des des cas
malheureusement de de corruption en
Guyane alors
jegerai je pense le dtpn parce que il a
je pense qu'il pourra vous éclaireer sur
une situation qui a été pas pleinement
prise en compte et qui est très
éclairante sur pour répondre à votre
question sur le GIR oui il existe un GIR
effectivement un GIR qui est commandé
par un officier de
gendarmerie et implanté ici sur Cayen
donc voilà qui travaille évidemment sur
toute l'économie
souterraine qui dépasse largement
d'ailleurs les trafics de mais qui alors
j'ai pas les chiffres exacts parce que
j'avais pas prévu la question mais on
doit être il m'avait fait un point assez
récent et cette année on est à plus de 3
millions d'euros de d'avoir
criminel des résultats qui sont en forte
hos
d'ailleurs merci
sur qui nous a pleinement touché
euh et
l'interpellation de plusieurs de nos
policiers adjoints qui é é affecté à
l'aéroport de de Cayen dans le casre
d'un dossier stupéfiant euh
identifi euh
et c'est l'opaste qui s'en
est
d'ailleurs une dizaine de garçons et de
filles
jour région Paris
euh
dispositif je rentrerai pas dans
les
depuis
livraison
grand il
sa Marie fin et puis même chose je veux
bien réponse écrite enfin n souhaitons
parce que ça coupe c'est c'est votre
micro je crois monsieur qui qui qui
fonctionne mal ou si vous n'avez qu'un
micro il y a une intervention qui va
moins bienux que les autres Marie l oui
merci président bonjour messieur alors
mais mes questions s'adressent à
Monsieur Richard Marie directeur
régional des douanes de guyan lors de
mon déplacement guyan avec le sénateur
sigigoloti ancien président de la
mission des formation sur le trafic de
stupéfiants en provenance de guyan nous
avions constaté que certains passagers
subissaient un contrôle à leur retour de
Paris ces contrôles permettent de
retrouver de l'argent liquide
certainement issu du trafic de
stupéfiants donc monsieur Marie
pouvez-vous nous faire un point sur ces
contrôles deuxièmement il semblerait
également que les boutiques de luxe des
aéroports parisiens soit des passages
obligés pour les mules qui rentrent en
Guyane existe-t-il des moyens de
contrôler les sommes dépensé souvent
liquide dans ses boutiques et pour finir
Gabriel Atal ancien ministre en charge
des comptes publics avait annoncé il y a
un an une augmentation des effectifs
douaniers notamment à l'aéroport
félixboué pouvez-vous faire le point sur
les effectifs vous manque-t-il encore
des agents pour bien pour mener à bien
vos missions je vous
remercie
classique
quasiment le
seul alors là là là on ne vous entend
plus du tout on vous entend plus du tout
est-ce qu'il y a moyen peut-être du coup
désactiver la caméra pour que le flux
aille sur le le son je ne sais pas mais
c'est très très difficile pour pour nous
vous entendre on est désolé hein demande
bien qu'il a des réponses écritesin ouis
et puis du coup on est preneur de de
réponse écrite à ces questions là mais
monsieur Gali veut prendre la parole je
vous en
prie on est en train
d'essayer monsieur Gal on vous entend
pas est-ce que le le le micro éta
activé
il on ne vous entend pas Monsieur
G pas du
tout on souffre avec vous mais vous
entends
pas peut-être du côté des quatre autres
si ça me fonctionne
mieux nous
onve
oui une question qui répondront parc
alors du coup ce ce qu'on comme on est
vraiment dans dans l'incapacité de vous
entendre dans bonnes conditions ce qu'on
va faire c'est encore vous adresser une
question qui pourra nourrir une réponse
écrite mais malheureusement la qualité
de l'audio est a décidé de d'empêcher
des échanges de bonne qualité Monsieur
califé Merci beaucoup moi j'ai deux
questions qui
sont très courte sachant que vous avez
parlé des contrôles au niveau de
l'aéroport pour des tion autre que pour
l'Europe je pense que vous faites des
des des contrôles sur l'ensemble des
destinations à partir de la Guyane pas
seulement vers l'Europe mais sur
l'ensemble des
pays d'Amérique du Nord de des Antilles
et cetera puis bien sûr vers la
Martinique et la Guadeloupe ça c'est ma
première question la deuxième qui est
liée à votre sécurité vous vous agent
agent de l'État même s'il n'y a pas de
gros bonnet il y a plutôt des petites
mains des des passeurs des mules comme
vous dites est-ce que votre sécurité est
menacé dans vos fonctions
euh on sait que c'est pas toujours
évident mais ça peut être aussi un un
problème et la dernière qui est
classique est-ce que vous avez des
coopérations avec les pays voisins
est-ce qu'il vous aident ou chacun pour
soit dans ce domaine
merci al je sais pas si on ose essayer
réponse orale
mais vous nous
ent non c'est pas pas suffisamment bien
pour que ça rende justice à la qualité
de vos
arguments ce que je proposeant l'État
sous le
l'œil approbateur du rapporteur c'est
qu'on en reste là en déplorant de pas pu
avoir tirer davantage d'information de
cet échange vous remercions pour
votre contribution et puis on va s'en
remettre à vos productions écrites pour
compléter les les informations qu'on a
pu avoir merci beaucoup msieur et puis
un peu frustré mais on vous lira avec
beaucoup d'intérêt
mercioir au revoir